what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with Jonathan Hickman's
Fantastic Four and the ending of this
story is craziest it's one of the
coolest endings ever because it sets the
stage for everything to come after but
one of the coolest things about this
comic book is until we get to the very
end there's no words there's no words
it's 100 artwork right so one of the
things that happens is that it's kind of
like the month of morning right so when
Johnny Storm when everything pops off
right the you know the Negative Zone
portal opens the Fantastic Four had
alerted like the Avengers and the
superheroes because they may needed them
at least you had Johnny and you had Ben
Susan and Reed again were not there at
the time that all that stuff popped off
but you basically have the Avengers who
show up here right the the new Avengers
who arrive on the scene but Johnny's
already gone right like he's already
dead and so they're too late and so in a
lot of ways it's pain and anguish on
their behalf especially from Wolverine
because it's kind of like No And this is
one of the coolest things to keep in
mind because you again one of the things
we talked about before is you don't see
the Fantastic Four as is a like a combat
team you don't really see them like
fighting threats in the same way that
you normally see The Avengers or the
X-Men dealing with threats but a lot of
that's because the Fantastic Four have
kind of transcended past this place of
like we fight your everyday villains and
they're more explorers than anything
else but they are a highly respected
team among the entirety of the superhero
Community if this was DC Comics The
Fantastic Four are Superman you know
what I mean it's that kind of a thing
and so everybody is basically looking at
this idea that like they're gone at that
moment the first member of the Fantastic
Four that wasn't there to arrive on the
scene is Susan's storm and she's
immediately given the news that her
brothers died and so once Reed arrives
on the scene he goes to visit Susan and
when he goes to talk to her she just
puts a force field around herself she
wants to be left alone she doesn't want
to be you don't want to talk to anybody
doesn't want to deal with anybody or
anything like that now one of the things
about this and what makes this so great
is because this is Jonathan Hickman
basically building on 50 years of
Fantastic Four stories right and the
reason why I say that is because what
made The Fantastic Four so unique in
Marvel Comics when they were first
introduced is unlike the Justice League
of America or anything like that this
team it was a team of family members
which meant they bickered like family
members they argued like family members
Susan storm and Johnny Storm are brother
and sister they've always kind of
bickered back and forth and they've had
their squabbles but at the end of the
day they squabbled the way they did
because there was love there because
they cared about each other and for her
to have her brother snatched out from
under her like that not only that to not
even be there when it happens and did
not have the ability to save him
completely and totally destroyed Susan
storm and so read in a moment of anger
actually goes to his Opera his work area
right in the Baxter building and he
grabs the ultimate nullifier now here's
the thing this is the Fantastic Four
this is the Marvel Comics equivalent of
just pressing the button right that's
literally what this is so when it comes
to the ultimate nullifier it's real
relative to the person using it so if
you put the ultimate nullifier in the
hands of a person who is basically
stupid they wouldn't really be able to
do a whole lot with it right they could
like blow up a car you put this thing in
the hands of Reed Richards you're going
to annihilate a universe right and not
only that not only does an ultimate
nullifier annihilate something it
basically removes it like it never
existed it quite literally destroys any
history of it this guy goes to the
negative Zone portal he goes to open it
up and he's immediately met by a
nihilist and a nihilus of course is the
last person really the first person that
Reid wanted to see so he could destroy
him and anihilus just holds up the shirt
of Johnny Storm he just holds it up as a
taunt to read Richards and Reed Richard
is just kind of feeling defeated
ultimately ends up walking away and so
what you get is this kind of funeral for
Johnny storm right where basically they
pay their respects and all that kind of
stuff because of all the things that
he'd done everything that he had been a
part of and there's this kind of
Vengeance right that everybody's sort of
feeling like something has to be done
about this we can't just let it be that
Johnny Storm died it can't simply just
go that way now the other part of this
and what's so ironic about this is that
while in in New York at the Baxter
building you have basically them
mourning over the death of Johnny storm
in latviria you have the commemoration
of Christoph Bernard right the adopted
son of of Dr Doom the one that Dr Doom
brought in to rule in his stead because
remember Dr Doom's intelligence was
basically screwed up by the
intelligencia he's not as smart as he
was before the other part of this is
that on day eight that's when you get
the actual funeral for Johnny Storm and
Dr Doom shows up to pay his respects and
that's one of the cool things right
Johnny Storm always kind of put off this
perspective in Marvel Comics that he was
the Playboy he's the guy he never takes
seriously you never Bank on Johnny Storm
you can never rely on Johnny Storm the
reality of this is that he's the guy you
wanted in your corner one because he was
just so damn powerful but two if he
cared about you he would go to the ends
of the Earth for you right he would go
to the limits for you it was absolutely
amazing and so what you also have is on
day 14 you have Franklin Richards
mourning the death of Johnny Storm now
here's the thing about this it's never
spoken here it's never said here and
there will be a conversation that takes
place between Spider-Man and Franklin
later on that we will cover but this
death of Johnny Storm is this probably
one of the most significant things to
happen to Franklin one of the most
important things to happen to Franklin
Richards and this is one of the things
that's going to push him over the edge
it's one of those things that's going to
elevate his power to a whole different
level but it's going to be done in an
amazing way it's really really cool
because there comes a point when he
freaks when he unleashes and when he
does oh my god when when Franklin
Richards goes off
it's just it's one of the best moments
in Marvel Comics history God I
absolutely love it but then you have
Valeria right with like the Future
Foundation all these young kids and
she's like okay so like here are
potential Replacements that we can
consider for somebody for for Johnny
Storm like black panther Wyatt Wingfoot
who was at one point kind of a mascot
for the Fantastic Four in the early days
She Hulk who was a member of the
Fantastic Four at one point and replaced
Ben Grimm for a while but at the end of
the day she's like no like we're not
going to replace Johnny Storm we're
going to put our minds to task we're
gonna find a way to kill annihilus and
like they're all behind it right now in
one of the More Beautiful Moments here
and it's it's so emotional and it's so
incredible you've got Ben Grimm dealing
with the death of Johnny Storm now
initially Ben Grimm is approached with
this kind of message right where it's
like these kinds of things happen in
life and and sometimes it's not fair and
and just sort of the good advice that
people try to give you when you're in a
time of mourning but as any of you out
there who have lost someone know
sometimes you don't want to just sit and
mourn sometimes you want to destroy some
and so where Ben Grimm rejects the the
conversation from anybody right where he
rejects the side this notion of you know
I should talk it through and all that
kind of stuff instead he's met by what
he needs the most because the two people
here are not arbitrary scientists
they're not just random guy guys who
showed up to deliver a message to Ben
instead it's Donald Blake and Bruce
Banner and they know what it is that Ben
Grimm needs they can take a beating just
like anybody else so Donald Blake slams
his stick on the ground he turns into
Thor and Bruce Banner becomes the
Incredible Hulk and in an effort to help
Ben Grimm deal with everything that's
going on the three of them engage in a
kind of three-way fight and it's such a
beautiful moment because it's not
fighting for the sake of fighting it's
because Ben Grimm's got so much anger
and he's got so much pain because he
feels like he should have been the one
to die he feels like he should have been
the one the one on the other side that
he should have been there and he could
have helped Johnny right if there was
something he could have done because the
reality is when you lose a loved one
it's regret it's pain it's sadness I
could have done something I should have
done something right if it's a situation
that's beyond your control that sense of
helplessness is an overwhelming and
dominating force and so when you have
like the Incredible Hulk and you have
Thor here that they basically helped Ben
Grimm work out all of his anger and all
of his frustration eventually he just
succumbs to tears and the Hulk does and
and Thor do and it's just this
incredibly emotional moment because you
have just these three huge guys who are
just crying over the death of a person
that meant the world to them but while
all of this is going on Reed Richards is
dealing with it as best he can but
always remember Reed has a million
things on his mind so while they're all
dealing while Susan storm and Ben Grimm
and them are dealing with the emotional
loss of Johnny Storm you have read
That's also dealing with the reality of
the situation that they're in Invasion
from the Negative Zone probability High
Invasion From The Universal Inhumans hi
Celestial Invasion via the bridge the
Mad Celestial showing up that's a medium
threat Franklin Richards power set his
ever expanding and growing powers that
threat is high the threat of Galactus
basically destroying the world High the
Reformation of the Council of reeds is
necessary and so as Reed Richards is
sitting there mulling over all of this
struggling with the loss of what's
basically his brother Johnny Storm
seemingly out of nowhere his father
reappears just shows up out of nowhere
and it's like hello son I'm home and so
what we end up doing here is we
transition right that moment we were
talking about that conversation that
takes place between Spider-Man and
Franklin when Spider-Man shows up to
visit Franklin this takes place on day
14. this is one of the most important
conversations because this is a Make It
or Break It point right remember
Franklin's a little kid but his powers
are back and I would go as far as to say
Spider-Man literally saved all of
creation here even if he didn't know it
because with Franklin Richards being a
kid that's so powerful that even
Galactus is afraid of him that speaks to
how powerful this kid is Peter Parker
showing up here this serves two purposes
one it does help to to you know Peter to
kind of relate to Franklin and help him
work through this but two it actually
starts one of the coolest friendships in
Marvel Comics because Peter's question
here is like how long have you been up
here and Franklin's like I don't know
but it's quiet up here and so Peter's
like okay like do you mind if I hang out
with you for a bit and the response of
Franklin is I guess not and that's one
of the things to know right for those of
you guys who have never dealt with
somebody who's dealing with grief and
grief comes in a lot of different forms
right grief comes in from a variety of
different sources if you've never been
around or dealt with anybody who is
going through grief it's not a matter of
demanding things it's not a matter of
saying this is what you need sometimes
it's just learning how to shut the hell
up and sometimes it's just learning how
to say I'm here if you need me because
sometimes all they want is to just be
there but they also want you want to
know that you're there and that's enough
that that's that's really all it is it's
not problem solving it's not getting
everything sorted out sometimes they
just want to sit there and be quiet and
then they just burst into tears or they
just start screaming and shouting or
something like that because that's what
they need in the moment what Franklin
needs is a friend and the reality here
is everybody is struggling with grief in
their own way that Franklin doesn't
really have anybody to turn to and so
turning to Peter he simply says like my
uncle Johnny died and the response of
Peter is yeah I know I'm very sorry
about that uh how are you doing with all
that stuff and Franklin again is kind of
having a conversation with a kid you
know I'm I'm not doing so well you know
I'm not really sleeping all that well
and I have I'm having bad thoughts I
want to hurt people I want to do bad
things right I want to destroy things
that kind of stuff right and again it's
a pause for concern it's like this is
not like a little kid who's just like
I'm really really angry you know and
it's like well how does that make you
feel you know you know draw on a piece
of paper with a crayon you know it's
like okay Franklin well please don't
destroy all of creation you know it's
that kind of a thing right it's that
kind of concern and so Peter Parker
actually ends up grabbing Franklin and
saying okay well let's go get some lunch
you know like like you know you want to
have you had any lunch or anything and
Franklin's like well I'm not really
hungry and Peter's like well I'm
starving right so let's go let's go get
something right let's spend some time
together and it's literally just Peter
Parker and Franklin Richards hanging out
together it's just them spending time
together because that's what Franklin
needs you just need someone to spend
time with him but at that point Peter
kind of opens up to Franco and says look
I don't know if your mom and dad ever
told you about this but when when I was
younger I lost somebody that was close
to me too you know like we were really
really close like you and your uncle
Johnny were close and and when Franklin
was like well what happened you know the
response to Peter is he was killed in a
robbery of course he's talking about
Uncle Ben and that's a really really
cool moment here because Peter's ability
to empathize with Franklin and to say
like I can understand where you're
coming from I don't know exactly how you
feel because I'm not you and in a lot of
ways how you cared about Uncle Johnny
was different than how I cared about
Uncle Ben or how I saw Uncle Ben I do
know what it's like to lose someone
close to me and the response of Peter is
you know me too you know I'm I'm sad
that happened and not a day goes by that
I don't think about him not a single day
goes by where that doesn't happen but it
doesn't make me sad anymore he says I
mean sure I wish he was still here and
God do I miss him but after a while the
dark thoughts the bad ones like you're
having right now they'll fade away and
you'll spend most of your time thinking
about how much fun you had together and
how much you loved him and so Franklin
of course asks the most logical question
there which is how long before that
happens and the response of Peter is it
takes a while and that's true there's
it'd be nice if it's human beings we
could say okay I've lost a loved one uh
in 30 days I'm gonna feel better in 30
days everything's gonna be okay in this
period of time everything will be better
but the reality here is that things
happen to us as human beings things
happen and it's not always fair and
there's no real Rhyme or Reason to it it
is sometimes it's just things that
happen in this world and there is no
deadline for the grieving process right
there is no amount of time that passes
before definitively everything will be
okay there are people out there who have
lost things that were meaningful to them
and they never recovered they never got
better they never bounced back whereas
there are people who had something bad
happen to them and they bounce back
fairly quickly there's no rules here and
that's what Peter's communicating to
Franklin is there's no rules on how long
it takes before these memories or these
thoughts that you have go away and
they're replaced by positive ones just
know that in time that happens in time
things get better and so Franklin says
can I tell you something can I tell you
a secret Spider-Man and Peter's like
yeah and he says I think I could have
stopped Uncle Johnny from dying now this
is an important thing and one of the
single most important things for
Franklin and it's so ridiculously easy
to overlook right it's so ridiculous and
I'm not I'm not even talking about well
you know he's taking the guilt on
himself no this thought right here this
statement I think I could have stopped
Uncle Johnny from dying you need to keep
that in the back of your head because
that single thought right there that
single motivation governs everything
that happens next every single decision
Franklin makes everything he does when
he's learning how to use his powers when
he's being trained by the man that he
doesn't recognize right the person he
doesn't know we'll cover that in future
foundation when all this stuff is
happening right all these things are
happening this is all governed by that
singular thought but the other part of
this is Franklin could have saved Uncle
Johnny from dying right had he possessed
more control over his abilities and I
don't say that because it's like
Franklin you idiot you know it's really
more of yes he's that powerful but it's
one of those things where this guilt
that he feels is going to be channeled
into something more productive and
Franklin is going to become more
powerful than he's ever been in the
history of Marvel Comics and so the
response with Peter is okay well I
promise I'll keep it to myself can I
tell you a secret and Franklin's
response is yeah and he says I know I
could have stopped my Uncle Ben from
dying and while the question of Peter or
a question of Franklin is why didn't you
you Peter gives this amazing statement
to Franklin which again this is why I
say this conversation is the most
important conversation Franklin's ever
going to have that Peter says because I
was young because I didn't understand
how important every single decision we
make is because I had to learn that when
you have gifts like ours you don't think
about yourself first you think about how
lucky you are to have them and how much
other people need help it's what my
uncle would have wanted from me and it's
what your uncle Johnny would have wanted
from you do you understand what I'm
saying and Franklin's response is yes
and so Peter says okay good now I gotta
get you home but this is a hugely
important conversation because Peter
Parker quite literally turned Franklin
Richards from this Anakin Skywalker
approach right just falling to Darkness
and just becoming this despotic
conqueror of the universe to a character
who's actually going to save everything
in existence because he does Franklin
Richards at the end of this story saves
the universe from complete and total
Annihilation and when I say the Universe
I mean he saved the Universe I mean it
quite literally it's one of the greatest
moments ever in the history of Marvel
Comics and I absolutely love it with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end next week we will
be back on Thursday to our regular
Fantastic Four schedule except in that
video we're going to be calling it The
Future Foundation because the name
changes but we're going to bring this to
an end thank you guys for watching and I
will catch you all later
peace